good afternoon so today I'm going to be
telling you about what we've learned
about the pathogenesis of our famous
disease through the study of genetics of
the disease
so how Slimers disease is one of the
causes of dementia there are about 50
different dementia causing diseases that
have been reported but about 60 to 70
percent of those cases dementia cases
are out sinus disease and as you can see
from this slide the other causes of
disease are much less frequent with the
second most frequent only representing
10 to 15% of cases and being dementia
with Lewy body disease
so our sinus disease is an extremely
common disease in the population about 4
million people in the u.s. currently
have Alzheimer's disease and around a
hundred thousand deaths per year can be
attributed to outsiders disease and the
risk of developing disease increases
substantially with age a younger people
the disease is extremely uncommon and in
people over the age of 65 it has a
frequency about 5% in the population
however as the population ages there is
a rapid increase in the number of people
developing disease so that in
populations over the age of 85 at least
30% of people are affected by
Alzheimer's disease ins in some studies
as number appears to be much larger so
what is Alzheimer's disease clinically
in neuro pathological II it's a dementia
and it's characterized by gradual onset
and progression of memory impairment and
this is combined with deficits in
executive functioning in language and
visual spatial abilities personality and
behavior and so over a period of 5 to 20
years people gradually get more and more
impaired and usually die from an inter
current infection as a result of being
but
and autopsy when you look at the brain
of an individual with Alzheimer's
disease you find two characteristic
pathological inclusions and here you can
see an example of the extracellular
amyloid plaque this is largely composed
of a peptide of 42:42 amino acids known
as beta amyloid the other in inclusion
that seen in Alzheimer's diseases
illustrated here oops and is called a
neurofibrillary tangles and these are
interested into neuronal inclusions that
are composed of hyper phosphorylated tau
in addition to these two proteinaceous
inclusions the most important feature of
our sinus disease is is neuronal loss
and a concomitant asteroid gliosis so as
I mentioned earlier the the major risk
factor for Alzheimer's disease is age
and that's illustrated in this graph
here where you can see that below the
age of 65 there is really a very low
prevalence of Alzheimer's disease in the
population but by the age of 90 a
substantial number of people over 50% of
people over the age of 90 have
Alzheimer's disease in addition to age
the other established risk factor for
Alzheimer's disease is family history
and family history certainly is
consistent with genetics playing a role
in disease although it could also be
obviously a common environment so what
do we know about the genetics about
Simas disease there are the disneys can
be generally divided into two categories
Mendelian form of the disease which is
usually has an early age of onset and
it's characterized by an autosomal
dominant pattern of inheritance so
receiving one
mutant copy of the disease gene from
your parents is sufficient to cause
disease in a child and mutations have
been observed in three different genes
that cause this Mendelian form of
disease the amyloid precursor protein
and then press on all in one and press
ml into that are two homologous proteins
the majority of Outsider cases have an
age of onset above 60 and so are not
kept classified as early onset but also
have a modest familial clustering rather
than a Mendelian form of inheritance and
among those cases of the disease the
most common genetic risk factor that's
currently known is the e4 allele of
April lipoprotein II so the next slide
here shows the mutations that have been
reported in familial Alzheimer's disease
and that the majority of these mutations
occur in personnel in one so eighty
percent about 80 percent of mutations
that have been reported occur in priests
and L in one and if one looks at the
data by looking at the number of family
as you can see again that about eighty
percent of families carry mutations in
personnel in one and where do you do it
by mutation number or family number
pretty consistently around fifteen
percent of families carry mutations in
the a P P G with the rarest form of this
form of disease being people who carry
mutations in personnel and to which
counts for about five percent and I
apologize for the mainly of the numbers
here there should be two hundred and
twenty three but you can see that there
have been out of five hundred and one
families that are being reported with
mutations in the literature in these
three genes two hundred and twenty three
different mutations have been reported
so most people carry or most families
carry a novel family
specific mutation and this has
implications for genetic testing and
genetic counseling because you really
need to do sequencing of the genes
rather than a screen for a particular
variance unless you know that a family
member has already has has already been
screened and had a specific variant
identified so what how do these
mutations cause outsiders disease what
do we think the pathogenic mechanism is
so this is some data from looking at
plasma from either people who carry
specific mutations in these genes or
from control individuals and so the red
bars on this graph show individuals who
are non non demented controls and on the
left-hand side of the graph we have the
plasma levels of beta amyloid that is
either 42 or 43 amino acids in length
and then on the right we have plasma
levels of a beta that's 40 ameno acids
in length so concentrating first on the
left hand side of the graph what you can
see is that what whatever the gene that
the mutate or whichever kind of mutation
you have that causes familial
Alzheimer's disease all of them are
associated with an elevated level of
plasma a beta 42 43 compared to the two
the controls on the right hand side you
can see looking at plans later a beta 40
that we see a different picture that for
most of these mutations the black bars
are far as of pressin L in one mutation
the yellow bar and a PP mutation and the
gray bar and personnel in to mutation
and all of these have similar levels of
a beta 42 controls in there's only one
mutation here which is a very specific
mutation called the Swedish mutation
that will come back to where you can see
in this example you have elevated a beta
42 here
and elevated a bit of 40 in this
individual and this permutation here so
this mutation is unusual most of the
others just cause the increase in a beta
42 so now looking at the more the apoe4
gene the major genetic risk factor for
sporadic forms about Simon's disease or
late onset forms about tsoumas disease
April II is known to transport
cholesterol in the periphery and is up
regulated in the brain and response to
injury most apoE is produced by
astrocytes within the brain and from a
genetic perspective the most important
features about this protein are the
presence of our polymorphisms at codon
112 here and codon 158 here in the
protein and if you look down at the
bottom left of this figure you can see
how these meter at these variants
combine to form the different alleles of
apoE
so there are three known forms of a
paper ve polymorphisms that are common
in the population apo III is the most
common polymorphism and is neutral with
respect to its risk for Alzheimer's
disease and as you can see at codon 112
a p3 has a cysteine residue and at 158
an arginine residue the next most common
allele in April II is a poly 4 and that
this is a risk allele for outside Miss
disease and it has arginine at both
residues within the protein in contrast
apoE 2 which is protective for disease
and cysteine residues at both of these
residues I believe for occurs at about
15% has an eel allele frequency of 15%
in the population in most populations
as you can see on the right-hand side of
this slide that that translates into
about two percent of the population who
are homozygous for this efore allele and
a quarter of the population who is
heterozygous for this variant and both
of these groups of individuals so
twenty-eight percent of the population
is an increased risk for developing
Alzheimer's disease by virtue of
carrying an AoE four allele so what do
we know about how apoe4 influences risk
for disease so the most compelling data
about the role of April week comes from
some transgender studies done in
transgenic mice by David Holtzman and
and colleagues and this is a summary of
data from his animal studies that
demonstrates that apoE
increases a beta deposition in mouse
models of Alzheimer's disease and in
this slide here you can see so this is
an AP p transgenic animal that develops
age dependent amyloid deposition these
animals were then crossed with animals
that had that Mouse ap we knocked out
and they're either human e2 e3 or e4
introduced into the mouse and you can
see that the apoe4 mouse has on the
right hand side of the slide here has
the most amyloid deposition in the in
the brain so these are from
eighteen-month-old animals and this is a
picture of the hippocampus stained with
an antibody to a beta and there's
extensive amyloid deposition throughout
the hippocampus in this mouse in the
middle you can see the April III Mouse
and this has much less deposition even
though the animal is the same age you'll
note in the right hand corner of the III
you need for my slide slides that there
there is
fire flavin s+ staining which means that
the a beta in these mice forms fibrils
and reacts with the fire flavin s in
contrast when you look at a pearly two
mice they show no evidence of fibrillar
a beta and the aid that the a beta that
is deposited appears to be deposited in
different layers the court of cortex
here so up in the right hand corner you
can see a summary of these results where
you can see that evil mice have
substantially more larger area of the
hippocampus occupied by amyloid beta
amyloid than in III e to or control
animals so the mechanism for this
amyloid deposition is thought to be at
least in part due to the fact that apoe4
is less efficient at clearing soluble
data amyloid and as a result you get
accumulation a beta as deposits in the
brain so to summarize them that this
part of the talk
all of these variants that we have found
that influence risk for out sinus
disease do so by affecting amyloid
precursor processing or metabolism and
this slide here illustrates a P P
metabolism so at the top of the slide we
have for length a P P and this a P P is
cleaved either by alpha secretase which
cleaves outside of the sorry within the
a beta sequins to generate two fragments
a ppes alpha and the CSD terminal
fragment this is then subsequently
cleared by gamma secretase to produce a
fragment called p3 and the intracellular
domain and this secretaries will cleave
a beta in all cells and
in but in neurons the beta Secretary's
enzyme is more prevalent and so a larger
proportion of a PP will go down the
pathway that's shown on the right-hand
side there so the EPP Swedish mutation
that I mentioned in an earlier slide
directly is a better substrate for this
data Secretary's enzyme and that's where
you get more a beta of all types
produced by this mutation beta
secretaries are the n-terminus of the a
beta fragment and then that is
subsequently cleaved by gamma secretase
which generates the a beta fragment and
as you can see on this slide priests and
knowing mutation so kreeson elements are
part of the gamma secretase complex and
mutations that are in the transmembrane
portion of a PP end up that are all
affected by all effect gamma secretase
cleavage ink cleavage to produce more a
beta 42 in contrast apoE has no effect
on a beta generation but it does affect
clearance and so a belief for hat is
less efficient at clearing beta amyloid
and may also have an effect on fibrillar
genesis of the a beta peptides that are
generated there are several mutations
within the AP p gene that occur within
the beta amyloid fragment some of these
are called the flemish the dutch and
optic mutations and each of these
mutations affects the physical chemical
properties of the beta amyloid fragment
and therefore affects fibrillar genesis
of the eight mutant a beta so in the
next part of my talk i want to talk
about some of the studies over the past
few years that have been used to
identify novel genetic risk factors and
the first approach that people have used
is called the genome-wide Association
study and genome-wide Association
studies arduous as they're commonly
called are designed to identify common
very
which usually have a small effect on
risk for disease this approach uses an
array based format that allows you to
simultaneously examine millions of DNA
variants in thousands or tens of
thousands of samples this is a most
common design for these kinds of studies
is a comparison of unrelated cases to
controls but it you can also use
quantitative traits such as in
neuroimaging data or fluid biomarker
measurements and geo studies generally
use very large sample sizes to give good
power for studies so the next slide
shows the results from a paper published
in Nature Genetics in November last year
which is a meta-analysis including data
from 74,000 80 cases and controls and
the this data here is the minus log 10
p-value against
chromosomal position with chromosome 1
on the left going up to chromosome 22 on
the right this is a a Manhattan plot and
all of the dots that are above the
horizontal bar represent genome-wide
significant associations and on each of
the chromosomes I've marked the names of
the genes that are represented by the
snips that are above this line so you
can see on the right a per we which is
the gene that we previously talked about
and then all of these other lows I have
our normal genes that have been
identified since the development of a
Jewess so what characterizes these novel
Geor signals is that they individually
had a modest effect on risk at the top
of this slide you can see the effect of
apoe4 which is if you carry one a little
copy of the e4 allele
you have an odds ratio of close to four
or a four fold increased risk for
developing disease if you carry an April
eater allele your risk is is hard so
about 0.5 in comparison these other
genes that were identified through the
Jewess studies have modest effects on
risk so you can see that clustering and
PyCon here have a risk that is about 10%
less there than if you didn't carry the
alleles in this gene conversely for ABC
a7 and for cr1 and bin 1 they're
associated with about 15 to 17 percent
increase in risk so in both cases these
are modest effects on risk but these
variants are common in the general
population so many people will carry one
or more of these variants that are
affecting risk at this point we don't
know the functional variants in any of
these genes but we do know that that
there that each of these genes are
contributing to risk for disease in
addition to looking using this gos
approach and looking at individual snips
or polymorphisms people have used
pathway analysis to evaluate look at
whether there are specific pathways that
have load P values in the jewish studies
and using this pathway approach a number
of different cake pathways have come out
as being significant so there are
multiple genes that are within the
immune system that affect metabolism
associated with cardiovascular risk
disease or not surprisingly
neurodegenerative disease and then other
molecules that seem to be involved in in
signaling so that seems to be from these
gos though
some evidence of particular pathways
that might be amenable to normal
therapeutic targets in the future the
second approach to identifying novel
genetic risk factors is to use
next-generation sequencing and this is
generally used to identify rare variants
in the population and the most
comprehensive approach to this kind of
sequencing is whole genome sequencing
where you get information at every
single base within the genome a slightly
check of course this is the most
expensive approach so a slightly cheaper
approach is to sequence the exome the
whole exome when this gets at the coding
sequences but gives you little to no
information about no non-coding regions
in the genome these are both unbiased
approaches looking surveying the entire
genome whereas another approach is to
use targeted sequencing as specific
candidate genes for example one could
sequence all of the genes identified in
the GI studies and see whether a rare
variants in those genes that also
contribute to risk for disease so again
a like the G where studies the
sequencing can be performed both in
unrelated individuals or in families and
the expectation of these rare variants
is that although they'll be rare in the
population they'll have a bigger impact
on risk in individuals who carry them so
among the first CSC sequencing studies
to be performed was one by Johnson and
Tom Johnson little-a decodes studying
the Icelandic population and when they
were sequencing doing whole genome
sequencing in the samples from the
Icelandic population they identified
this mutation in the AP PG ap P a 673 t
and the interesting thing of
this mutation was it it appears to
protect people from developing
Alzheimer's disease and it does this
because it reduces cleavage of a P P by
the enzyme base and so in this this
slide here showing data from that paper
you can see in the table that the
frequency among 80 cases of this variant
is 0.13% so it's relatively rare less
than 1% in the population but when you
look at the frequency of this population
in 80 cases versus cognitively normal
individuals you see that it that it is
much less frequent in 80 cases and so
when you compare it to the general
population the risk is about 1/4 if you
carry this variant if you come if you
look at the bottom of this table and you
compare the frequency of this varying in
80 cases to cognitively intact
individuals who are over the age of 85
you can see that that the odds ratio
drops further to 0.13 or 13% so really
these individuals have that about 6
times less likely to develop Alzheimer's
disease if they carry this variant then
than the general popular then if they
don't carry this variant and the reason
for that is shown in the slide at the
bottom here so if we look on will look
up the right hand graph we can see that
because so this is measuring theta
amyloid again in a in a cell culture
system in the first block we had this is
the level in this column here on the on
the left you can see this is the the
level of a beta generated from wild-type
sequence of a PP next to that in the
second column over you can see the
levels of a beta generated when you
express this Appa six seven three t so
it looks it's less than half of the
level that you see for the wild-type
protein interestingly a mutation that
the same residue but a different
mutation that's been associated with
increased risk for Alzheimer's disease
had shown has a higher level of a beta
than wild-type sequence and then the
highest one here is the Swedish mutation
that I've mentioned to you previously
that Cleaves a increases cleavage by
base so here we can see there the the
lowest cleavage by base is associated
with protection from out Simon's disease
and the highest cleavage by base is
associated with highest risk of
developing disease so people have been
using the next-generation sequencing now
but only a couple of years but during
that time three different genes have
been studied and shown interesting data
so I've shown you the first one which
was a protective variant within a PP
gene the next two examples I'm going to
show you are from normal genes that were
came out of sequencing studies and the
first of these came from the same group
in in Iceland the decode group are on
the right and on the left we have a
paper that was published simultaneously
in the New England Journal from Rita
Cuero and John Hardy's group in
University College London and both of
these groups by using next-generation
sequencing identified variants within
this gene trem to or triggering receptor
expressed on myeloid cells - and they
identified the in those studies they
identified the variant that shown on the
right here are 47 H in trend 2 and this
is Metro analysis of some data published
in a paper by Bennett eyes out until
earlier this year showing that the odds
ratio for carrying this variant in trend
2 is to about 2 so I'll say my cases you
carry are 40 separate how about double
the risk of people carrying this variant
have double the risk of developing
Alzheimer's disease interestingly so
trend 2 is part of a gene family
there are several genes in the gene and
one of the other genes in this gene
cluster tran l2 also appears to show to
have variants that affect risk for
disease and on the left-hand side of
this figure you can see the tremor l2
variant the S 144 Jeep amino acid
substitution and it's meta-analysis here
is associated with reduced risk of
developing Alzheimer's disease so people
who carry this variant have a somewhat
less likely to develop Alzheimer's
disease than people with a wild-type
trend trend to l2 sequence so again like
it in the apoE gene in Trenton this gene
cluster there are both risk factor
variants like the r-47 H in trend too
and protective variants like the trem l2
variant with respect to Alzheimer's
disease so the most recent identify
study identifying an ad gene was
published by crucian Gretel in just at
the end of the beginning of this year in
January and this study I used started
off with 14 late onset Alzheimer's
disease families and uses a strategy
where
they sequenced to affected individuals
from each family and one control and
using their sequence data they filtered
it to identify the variants that were
present in both the cases but were
absent in the unaffected controls and
then since the hypothesis was that this
was a rare variant they looked at the
variants that had a frequency of less
than half percent in the general
population and on around 75
nonsynonymous variants per family were
identified by doing that these variants
wouldn't genotyped in the remaining
family members which was generally about
another ten to fifteen individuals among
these individuals they identified the
variants that showed perfect segregation
with disease so were present in the
cases but not present in unaffected
controls who were elderly and this
reduced the number of variants down to
about eight variants per family looking
at cross families they observed that
there was one variant that was present
in more than one family and this was the
valine to Matheny that residue to 32 in
phospholipase d3 or PL d3 so this
suggested the P LD 3 might this variant
might be a normal risk risk factor for
Alzheimer's disease and this slide here
shows the two categories that were
studied in studied and you can see that
in in each family there are multiple
generations with affected individuals
shown by the shaded individuals and if
you look there are several families
sorry several individuals here with A+
and these were affected individuals who
were screened and carried the V to 32 M
variant in this family and similarly in
this family there's one here and then
cousins over here who also were affected
and carried the variant and then again
sorry there's siblings and an individual
here so in this in both families the
variant segregated with disease in the
family and supported the hypothesis that
this was causing disease this variant
was then genotyped in two additional
series a family cases and controls
identified from family series and then a
sporadic series of cases and controls of
as you see here and looking in the odds
ratio : you can see that in each
individual series and in the Metro
analysis of this data that this variant
was associated with a power to fold
increase in risk for Alzheimer's disease
so this supported the notion that PLD 3
is an outside gene and that this
particular variant increases risk for
disease we subsequently went on to
sequence this PLD 3 gene in 4,000
individuals to look for additional
variants and in this slide here you can
see a schematic of the protein shown
across the top and then the exons of the
gene with each of the variants variants
that was identified in this sequencing
project along the bottom the variants
that are shown in red were individually
in a single snip analysis associated
with risk for Alzheimer's disease so the
B 232 M is in the middle and that's the
variant that we initially found and then
you can see that there are two
additional variants m6r whoops and a
4-4-2 a so a synonymous variant that
showed significant association on their
own in these
in a test for association in cases in
controls so the most powerful way to
analyze data from looking at rare
variants is rather than to do a single
variant analysis which needs very very
large sample sizes is to do what's
called a gene based analysis where you
pull all of the rare variants into a
category and test whether carrying a
rare variant in the gene increases risk
for disease or alters risk for disease
and in this slide you can see that that
both in European Americans and in
african-americans people who carried a
rare variants in PLD 3 we're at
increased risk for developing out Simas
disease so you can see here in europeans
that there was an odds ratio of 2.75 and
if we remove the original variant that
v2 32m we still see an odds ratio of
2.58 suggesting that there are
definitely additional variants in this
gene that increased risk for disease
although the African American dataset
was smaller we still saw a very
substantial increase in risk in this
case the risk of the odds ratio is five
point four eight so more than a five
fold increase in risk for developing
Alzheimer's disease if an individual
carried a rare variant in PLD three so
combined this provides very strong
evidence that there are multiple
variants in PLD 3 that can increase risk
for developing outside missis's so what
is PLD 3 and how is it affecting risk
for disease so it PLD 3 is a non
classical member at a phospholipids d
superfamily that's illustrated up here
there are six members of actually I have
5 here but there's recently been
six-member described and what makes them
non-classical there are two things first
even though they have that HKD split
catalytic domains like ple one appealed
it to purely three has no reported
phospholipase d activity and as a result
we really don't know what the function
of pol III is they also missing the PX
domain and the pH domain so these
domains are our domains that purely one
and PLD to use to localize them to
membranes for PLD 3lakhs this structure
even though it is localized to the
endoplasmic reticulum and lastly from
some initial functional studies it's
been demonstrated that peel d3 is
upregulated during Maya Genesis and
neurogenesis but what role it's playing
is currently unknown so to look at them
at the some of the variants that we
found to try and understand the
mechanism at action here we had done a
number of cellular assays so the first
one here is this synonymous variant a
4-4-2 a which appears to modify ASP
Landsat splicing enhancer binding site
and on the right hand side of this slide
you can see that the residue that is
changed in by this polymorphism is this
large G here so there's a polymorphism
causes the G to be an A and the people
with the rare variant and you can see
from this figure here that this the size
of these bases reflects the importance
of that sequence within the splicing
enhancer binding site and the G is the
most important base for those particular
enhancer binding site and so when you
have replaced that G by an A
you can see on the left hand side that
the splicing drops by more than 50% in
individuals who carry the a allele
indicating that this variant sequence is
a very poor substrate for the splice
splicing enhancer and that's further
demonstrated on the this next slide
where you looking across a variety of
exons within the gene by using rt-pcr
you can see that consistently in
individuals who carry the a 4-4-2 a
variant that there is less expression of
the actor of each of these exons
relative to X are 14 suggesting that
there is alternative splicing occurring
that reduces the amount of these exons
present compared to the wild type
sequence so this next slide evaluates
both overexpression and knockdown a PL
d3 in a neuroblastoma cell into a cells
that are stably expressing human a PP
and as you'll see there they produce
overexpression and knock down the peel
d3 it produces opposing effect on a beta
for 40 and 42 production so in the top
slide we you can see that we have here
PL d3 expression this is a PP expression
in the top and PLU 3 expression in here
and in in the left-hand Lane this is the
control and then if we look at the the
graphs on on the right so the middle one
here on the top is looking at a bait of
two levels in the culture medium and you
can see that when you express
overexpress wild-type PLD three the
levels of are a bit of forty to drop
compared to the control without PL d3
expression similarly if you're looking
at a bit of 40 on the right hand side
here the over expression of wild type PL
d produces less a beta 40 than the
control cell without PL d3 and on the
bottom we have this is the knockdown
experiment and you can see here that the
PL d3 shrna reduces PL d3 expression in
these cells and when we look at the a
beta levels now knockdown appeal d3
increases a beta 42 and increases a bale
of 40 so over expression of PL d3
reduces a beta levels and knockdown and
PL d3 increases a beta levels so this
would suggest then that the variants
that have been reported that increased
risk for out same as disease are likely
to be a loss of function or a partial
loss of function based on this data so
in summary then 80 has a complex genetic
architecture and April II is the only
common variant of large effect other
variants are either wear or end of large
effect or common and have small effect a
beta production and clearance is likely
to be central to ad pathogenesis and
examples of that are the AP p pressin
Ilyn and a poly all effect a beta
production enters PL d3 and several
lines of evidence suggests that innate
immunity influences ad risk with
examples of trend to and travel to for
rare variants and c d3 and CR one for
common variants and then lossy
protective and risk alleles may occur
in the same gene or gene families and
that's was illustrated by April II a PP
and then the trend to travel to variants
so lastly I just like to acknowledge
that all of this represents work by a
great many collaborators and by people
in my lab and I also acknowledge the
funding sources for this work thank you
very much so there's a question
regarding the the Down syndrome and
Alzheimer's disease and so most people
who develop who everyone with Down
syndrome most people with Down syndrome
will develop Alzheimer's disease if they
live long enough and it's certainly been
and the reason for that is that people
with Down syndrome have three copies of
chromosome 21 and a P P gene is located
on chromosome 21 and so people with Down
syndrome have an overexpression of a P P
and therefore generate more beta-amyloid
peptide is also been demonstrated there
people with Down syndrome who carry an
e4 allele will generally develop a
amyloid deposition and cognitive and
further cognitive impairment at an
earlier age than people who carry other
alleles of a police so it does seem as
if that that the genetic factors that
influence out signers disease also
influenced the development of Alzheimer
pathology and impairment in people with
trisomy to as you were
second question are there are any
examples of genetic influences to tell
protein misfolding or hyper
phosphorylation so interestingly there
have been a number of mutations that
have been reported in the gene encoding
the tau protein and those mutations lead
to a different dimension called
frontotemporal dementia so the there are
no there are no mutations that have been
reported in the tau protein that cause
Alzheimer's disease but they do cause
another dementia there are also there's
a common risk allele within the tau tau
gene which is associated with
development and other telepathy so there
are a number of diseases where those
tangles occur in the brain
other than Alzheimer's disease an
example would be progressive
supranuclear palsy where carrying the H
1 1/2 a type in the tau protein
substantially increases your risk of
developing PSP and similar results have
been seen from frontotemporal dementia
and so but not the data for Alzheimer's
disease I would say is less compelling
there's some evidence that this
haplotype may also wreak influence risk
for Alzheimer's disease but I think this
is less compelling there is some
evidence though their variants that
alter the levels of tau in the CSF might
be associated with differences in the
rate of decline of Alzheimer's disease
amongst people who are already
symptomatic so it could be that
variation in tau has an effect on the
rate of progression of disease rather
than your risk for developing
so what is the possible mechanism for
purely three use to regulate
extracellular a beta at this point we
don't know the answer to that it could
be that is involved altering trafficking
or it could be involved in affecting so
it could be trafficking of a PP at South
or it could be affecting the enzymes
that cleave a PP and that's something
that we are working on at this moment I
don't have an answer for you exactly
what it's doing
you
so finally if you want to obtain
continuing education credits please go
to the by fire conference live website
where you'll be able to obtain those
thank you very much